continuing our coverage of the 2020
scouting combine in indianapolis joining
us now
the man who discovered patrick mahomes
he is chief's general manager
brett veach i love the story of how you
just banged on the drum and banged on
the drum i mean everybody knew he was a
first-round prospect but you guys
figured out you figured out how good he
was going to be and i think the other
part of it that was genius was keeping
it quiet yeah right yeah because if it
gets out then maybe some of these teams
at the top of the draft start taking a
closer look and the next thing you know
you can't get him it's hard enough to go
from 27 to 10. get it from 27 to 2 to
get him so congratulations number one on
discovering him and number two on
keeping it quiet that's the hardest part
uh and i think you know during that
draft process we knew that basically we
weren't going to be able to be able to
get higher than 10. so you're right and
you're sitting there thinking
you know i think we're ahead of the
curve on this kid and um
we have a plan to get him but you know
if it gets out it's not going to take
teams at 11 12 30. it's an easy move to
go from 12 or 13 to 10 as opposed to 27
and 10 so we were kind of locked into 10
and we needed the cars to fall in an
exact way and unfortunately for us they
did did you have an inkling at the time
of maybe the two or three other teams
that were hot on them you know
you know listen i did a lot of work you
like to think that you were trying to
survey the landscape and i you know you
certainly heard the cardinals and maybe
the the saints and they're you know it's
it's no coincidence they were 11 and 12
and we got to 10. right right um but
honestly the day of the draft felt
really good um
but
when trubisky win it too
typically the way these drafts work when
one position goes they're just starting
to run right so
you think to yourself wow
one's already off the board yeah he
might not make it to us but uh one
cincinnati turn at the card i think it
was john ross and a lot of high fives
and a lot of celebrating yeah
so you're just watching it every pick no
you're just holding your breath when
that pick goes and you you're looking to
see if the if the commissioner's mouth
is starting with a
like you don't want that pot to come out
really it's the computer because the
computer splits the name out so i think
i caught myself for those first night
pictures staring at the computer just
looking for the names to go across the
screen that's right because you guys
know in advance yeah yeah it's like a 20
second yeah
it comes on the screen so um just caught
ourselves staring at the start of the
computer monitors but um the palms were
sweaty and there was a little bit of
nervousness uh until cincinnati turned
the card in did you know you had to get
ahead of the saints in the cardinals
well we knew that that uh
the likelihood of uh selecting him
once it got to them would be lower and
lower now listen maybe they went a
different direction maybe they thought
about trading back up in late one you
don't know but you know that these are
teams that have done
um
more extensive work on mahomes i mean
when you sit there and you're going
through unfortunately i had a good
relationship with with
past agent chris cabot
and you start
compiling information
and
you realize that there are some teams
that are showing a higher probability
because of they're doing more visits
they're interacting more and those teams
um more so than others um were way out
in front in regards to some of the work
they've done that you realize once you
get to those teams and you know the risk
becomes a lot greater
so when did you stop celebrating are you
done celebrating yet well you know it's
it's a little bit different in our deal
here because i mean we won the super
bowl we get back on monday
organizational day tuesday parade
wednesday and then
you know we always meet for 14 days
before the combine right well because we
were in miami we were six days behind so
literally that thursday uh me and my my
scouting staff we were in the um in the
office at 7am and we were just cranking
through the tape so it was really
business as usual so i don't know if i
had a chance to celebrate a joke with
coach all the time coach is sending me
pics from california and we're in the
draft i don't know about this business
as usual thing on a thursday i'm
throwing the challenge flag on that but
here's the thing
because you're putting all in all that
work to eventually win the super bowl
hey we just won the super bowl right i i
like it i'm sure it takes even more
discipline in the aftermath of winning
the super bowl to dot your eyes and
cross your teas and do everything you
need to do because the train keeps
rolling year after year yeah because
everyone will be celebrating kansas city
and you know how this works i mean as
soon as you get here and the off season
starts i mean no one really cares
anymore i mean it's uh
but you do have to find that that moment
and that time to sit back and and you
know just um celebrate with with the
people in the organization um but i
think you know the combine being such a
quick turnaround really just forced you
to like you said stay disciplined and
stay after your craft
which one did you say oh crap we're done
more in 24 or nothing to the texans or
20 to 10 with the 49ers was there one
there
where you were like oh crap we're done
the texans ones i was like i think they
could still come back yeah i would agree
you know the niners game because it was
now it was so much later in the game i
mean you're talking 2010 in the fourth
quarter
houston happened so fast
that even though
it wasn't an ideal situation to be in
you looked at the clock and you saw
there's so much time left in the game
whereas the niners and and given their
defense right how how stingy they've
been all year you looked at the clock
and you're like twenty ten seven minutes
in the game right we gotta go so it was
a little bit more plus the stakes were
a little bit higher too so
it was amazing i'm still blown away by
it i can't like i can't even i it's
amazing one of the things that impressed
me the nfl films package that culminated
in that third down play yeah the 44-yard
gain from patrick to tyreek hill the
leadership that patrick was showing on
the sidelines down 10. talking to guys
like tyreek hill to keep his head in the
game i mean that's one of those things
that you can look at all the film you
want you don't know that he's going to
be that guy until he's there and i think
that's one of the things about patrick
mahomes that that pushes him over the
top and and puts him in already one of
the all-time greats yeah and that's like
you said i mean listen all throughout
the league and year in and out there's
always
i mean this league doesn't lack for
talent so you're gonna have guys that
are extremely mobile guys that have arms
and this and that but it's really those
moments that i mean until you experience
um and go through those moments that you
know what you really have and
pat is so unique in the ability and i
tell the guys all the time when people
want to ask about pat pat has the
ability to go out there and play and and
and
perform in a game similar to like when
you're in your backyard playing with
your friends yeah he has the ability to
play in front of a big audience
and he gets into the zone where it's
really just backyard football right and
it's there's no stress he's unphased
it's it's it's crazy but when you saw
the way when you call it let's run this
play why not it doesn't matter what down
i don't know it's crazy yeah i it is you
know and i don't know if you heard us on
the show but like you know i know my dad
got done with the game against you guys
in the titans and he said one of the
things the titans coach just kept saying
is we're not going to blitz him because
you can't rattle the guy yeah it's not
he's never been rattled in his three
years as a quarterback and
are you amazed by that yeah i mean you
think it's it's crazy it has to go back
to all the years i think growing up in a
clubhouse right being around
large crowds and and uh professional
athletes it really
nothing is the moment is never too big
yeah because he doesn't really have to
deal with um
any environment that is uncomfortable
for him
when does he get that second contract
that everyone thinks is going to be 40
million he'll be the one to break the
barrier 40 million per year well is
there a timetable for getting that done
yeah i mean it's a great question i
don't know if there's a timetable we
have time and he's not listen he's going
to be a
chief quarterback for a long long time
um certainly there with the cba
looks like it's going to get worked out
and um you know there'll be some
dialogue there that we'll have to work
through um and then just really just
trying to and i think the cool thing
about pat and his agent is they realize
that you know he's going to make a lot
of money but they also realize that you
know no one
operates in the sense of taking the
extreme team discount but pat is also
very cognizant of wanting to be
um in a place like kansas city and win a
lot of super bowls and there are some
things um to help the team to make sure
there's always town around him so it'll
take time it'll get done right um but
he's one of those uh kids he's a special
kid and his agent they want to make sure
he's surrounded with a bunch of talent
too because i mean he's he's chasing
rings and that's a good thing a good
situation for us to be into yeah we
argue about this a lot i i mean we do i
mean i'm always like ultimately if he
makes 42 million a year a year if he
takes 38 it's not gonna make it still
four million dollars a year i know but
it is a lot i get it i'm not trying to
disrespect it right but he
he he thrives on winning yeah and he
there's also an element of just real and
you know obviously the more money a team
has the more talent they can surround
and it'll be one of those things that
it'll get done it'll take time like they
all do but
at a certain time of point it'll make
sense for us it'll make sense for them
and everybody be happy you get input on
the roster do you get input on the super
bowl ring
um in regards to just the design yeah
you know my take is that uh i think uh
clark and his uh wife tavia are working
on that and i'm sure coach will get a
look at it but i think it's hard to i
don't know i've never won one before but
i'm assuming it's hard to screw it up
right right oh yeah it's hard to screw
it up just make it big and shiny and
everyone's gonna be happy where will you
keep it will you wear it uh i would wear
that damn thing every day i'd wear it in
the shower i'd wear it in the swimming
pool i'd wear it when i sleep i'd never
take it off yeah that's a great question
i haven't even thought about that i'm
anxious to see what it looks like and
i'm sure there'll be some special
moments where you want to break it out
and other than that i'm sure have a
place for it yeah in a safe somewhere
okay right
and i i you're not gonna like this get
ready we have a big enough place because
it ain't going to be the only one yeah i
hope so it's not going to be the only
one you're going to have you're going to
have a whole family of them yeah but
it's going to look like they're
reproducing by the time it's all said
patrick mahomes so congratulations on
getting that yeah i want to ask one more
thing just as like we talked about
mahomes there's chris jones chris jones
i mean is that priority number one right
now yeah i mean listen i mean you know
when you do something that hadn't been
done in a franchise for 50 years that
when a super bowl um you realize that
you had a talented team yeah and you
know when you get frank clark and chris
jones you know on that defensive line um
to go with pat mahomes on the offensive
side that's a there's no better place to
start um there'll be some difficulties
and some challenge challenges for us and
you know to manipulate everything but
it's certainly something that we want to
get done and we're going to work to see
if we can make it happen yeah all right
brett congratulations man it's been fun
to watch go chiefs and super bowl they
got their own camera now look that's the
chiefs they're big time all right we're
going back more from indy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports